about the collaboration center  foundation launching new projects at a  five acre ranch down in the southwest  valley foundation leaders with a  ceremony of groundbreaking yesterday at  their property on windmill near durango  so this nonprofit focuses on community  inclusion for folks with intellectual  developmental and physical disabilities  they're putting in a grab and go  restaurant for families and clients who  are being treated there at the ranch  they also have plans for classrooms a  health clinic and even an amphitheater  it really is a truly amazing and special  day for us and i think even more so for  our community our disability community  because this campus that's going to be  starting to be built next month is going  to really save and change a lot of lives  the center serves people and families of  all ages in need and eight news now is  proud to have the collaboration center  as one of our community pride partners